welcome to the reason live stream I'm
Zach Weissmuller joined by my colleague
Nick Gillespie
hi Zach and today our guest is Cody
Wilson many in our audience will be
quite familiar with him but for the
unacquainted he is the founder of
Defense distributed the company
responsible for the first ever 3D
printed gun known as The Liberator and
the manufacturer of the ghost Gunner a
popular DIY milling machine that enables
anyone with access to the internet to
generate an unregistered firearm from
the comfort of his or her own home
defense distributed almost since its
Inception has been party to multiple
lawsuits fighting federal and state
governments for the right to host
digital gun schematics on their website
defcad and to sell their Ghost Gunners
and accessory components their latest
fight is against the Biden
administration's ATF which issued a rule
attempting to regulate components known
as 80 percent lower receivers which is
where we'll start this conversation Cody
thank you very much for joining us today
hey thank you guys good afternoon happy
to beard right so Biden's ATF submitted
a new rule last year targeting
unregistered ghost guns before we get
into the content of that rule let's just
take a look at what Biden had to say
about the threat of ghost guns as
justification for the atf's actions
this is the gun
it's not hard
to put together
fell in the terrorist a domestic abuser
can go from a gun kit
to a gun as little as 30 minutes in fact
the ATF reports that they've been able
to trace less than one percent less than
one percent
of ghost guns reported by law
enforcement and we're acting today the
United States Department of Justice is
making it illegal for a business to
manufacture one of these kits without a
serial number illegal
illegals what's your reaction Cody
I'm immediately reminded of Dr Steve
Brule played by John C Reilly and his
famous Sushi skit on check it out he
says uh
it's not hard to let other people from
different countries talk to you he said
he sounds exactly like Dr Steve brol so
maybe that's a deep cut but uh I feel
bad for the president you know and that
was a great moment for polymer 80
because of course Joe Biden's rule was
workshop for him by every town in
Giffords to Target what had become a
very popular type of at-home kit DIY kit
for making concealable unregistered
handguns the polymer 80 kit that was
it's it's great moment so yeah it's fun
to see it again
yeah and uh so we're everyone's kind of
on the same page about what we're
talking about here
um these are examples of 80 lowers and
Frames
um and so basically the government uh
wanted to the ATF once you classify
these as something that had to be
registered I talked with you uh last
January uh shortly after this uh this
rule was first published by the ATF and
I'm just going to play a quick clip from
that that conversation because it
quickly explains kind of the mechanics
here and then we can discuss you know
how things have progressed since then
if the rules adopted in the coming weeks
it means the federal government will
require gun Park kits sold on the
Internet by defense distributed and its
competitors to Bear the same serial
numbers as do fully manufactured
Firearms which has the potential to put
the entire industry out of business so
how is Wilson responding
meet the zero percent receiver anything
on its way to being a gun is now
considered a gun so say aye Uncle Joe
and this would be smart you would think
if you're a wine mom or a lawyer who Now
controls the ATF you know this is Gabby
Gifford's Grand achievement to end kit
guns in the mail but that's just it this
was only a reaction to Kit guns in the
mail our equipment our software 3D
printing and CNC milling can take raw
materials
blocks of metal things in their
primordial State and take them from
nothing and turn them into guns Wilson
and his team tweaked the code to the
latest model of the ghost Gunner it used
to be the customers would purchase
partially fabricated lower receivers
using the ghost Gunner to finish the job
of turning them into functional gun
parts Wilson said that defense
distributed is the only DIY Gun Company
pivoting in the face of this new
regulation so the real impact of the law
will be to drive out his competitors
with this rule that Biden's pursuing
he's giving us the nation's Premier
Ghost Gun Company I would say a monopoly
of the market
so how how has it played out since then
you know in terms of adoption because
when we're talking about going from
something that's partially finished to
something that's a raw material I
imagine that's a little bit more work
have people been ordering these and and
making things out of the zero percent uh
receiver blocks or non-receiver blocks
thank you
uh yeah since since our piece and your
piece thankfully was a big part of
adoption our centerpiece yes we did
about a solid Year's worth of business
with the with the ar0 and it was it was
cool we took it to SHOT show unssf shot
show lots to say about that organization
right now but people got it yeah people
bought a lot of it and they got it but
what's so interesting is like at the
time that I spoke to you we were
predicting a more effective rule that
would actually ban entirely most 80
receivers or receiver kits and certainly
the language at that time time suggested
as much and by the time the final rule
was published we were all surprised that
most 80 receivers survived and so you
ended up getting these pieces like in
the New York Times and
um all these gun controllers came out
with buyers remorse saying well actually
the rule wasn't what we thought it was
and and so the to some degree in that in
that next year after that piece AR zeros
or zero percent receivers didn't become
necessary uh because the Monopoly wasn't
required the the industry survived and
in fact began to abuse the rule in
different directions so it's awesome and
hilarious that we didn't have to go that
way so the new conversation the new zero
we have today I'll I can show you it has
a retrospective point of view instead of
this predictive one that that we had
with you at that time that's one way to
answer your question
yeah tell us a little bit about this new
uh product that you're you're launching
now um and I do uh I received your video
that is uh kind of announcing that so
maybe we'll we can play that real quick
and then you can explain exactly what
this is and why you think that it's a
necessary next step I will and can
sorry come on I had some thoughts about
that that period you know with Joe yeah
I know since we're not compressed for
time if you don't mind please do um you
know I learned things beyond what I was
sharing with you there about the rule at
that time in the video and that the rule
actually did begin the so-called frame
and receiver rule Ghost Gun World it did
begin in contemplation of how to of how
the ATF could regulate any any new part
of a gun because it they were thinking
of 3D crime
um The Wall Street Journal at the time
was reporting that it was an industry
move to cut down just on polymer 80 kit
but there were contemplations of well
people are Printing and doing whatever
they want so we need ways to assign you
know more than one receiver potentially
to new types of designs or guns um but
that was written out pretty quickly in
early drafts some of the language kind
of survives uh by reference or something
so you kind of you kind of see it
echoing around in the final rule but
that final rule is really mysterious so
in the end they just settled on things
like well of course we can't regulate
things in their primordial State when I
used that word that wasn't you know I'm
not trying to be elaborate like that's
the legal thing that they say themselves
in the rule and they kind of gave up on
the idea uh most recently under under
litigation that they could regulate
certain types of receiver kits and
they've even lost the ability to
regulate the pulmonary kit because of a
lawsuit in the Northern District of
Texas called vanderstock and so the
context of this new 80 receiver kit you
could say or zero percent receiver kit
we have is it's based off that fight in
the Northern District of Texas it's
called vanderstock
fpcs in it there's a couple other
companies in it and that judge O'Connor
he's a trump judge he's already kind of
indicated that he's going to throw out
Biden's ghost gun rule entirely and so
this is like this is the bookend on this
little three-year program we've had
together right Joe Biden
could you talk a little bit about why
was the rule
um you know why didn't it work uh it
seems like it should be pretty
straightforward for the government to
say you can't sell this thing in this
shape without uh you know an ID number
or something like that why you know why
did the 80 percent rule fail I think the
government would agree with you here but
basically this like the expansion of the
regulatory state in most directions it
was by the ATF on its own was trying to
rewrite the gun control Act Right
firearm is a term defined by Statute
defined by Congress and in this little
fiction we maintain about you know who
has the legislative power we say it's
Congress and so it was quite simple in
the end they through 100 Pages at trying
to rewrite what the word firearm meant
and what the word firearm receiver but
these are defined by Statute um in the
GCA and not really modified in other
places and so they bit off more than
they could chew it was overreach and
finally I mean this wasn't the only
challenge vanderstock against the rule
but finally we the ATF met a judge who
said no actually Congress defines what
firearm is not you and so either things
are firearms or they aren't and it
doesn't matter if something's can become
a firearm it's simply legally and
materially is not one until it is one
you know Therefore your rule is
unconstitutional it's a pretty simple
pretty Stark and the way you hope
constitutional cases on these questions
go of course it's pretty difficult to
get those outcomes
do you worry at all about
um you know I'm thinking of like the
installment of a gun though
um back in 2019 reason ran a story by
Jacob solomwich dealt with drug
paraphernalia where it turns out you
know the the kind of reigning
definitions of drug paraphernalia say a
glass pipe or a glass sculpture you know
it's a bong but it would be not it
wasn't sold as a bond if it's in a head
shop and if it's in proximity to to weed
then it was drug paraphernalia which
could be restricted by law if it was
just on somebody's shelf somewhere or
you were buying it off of Amazon it was
not and I mean it gets to this kind of
murky strange space of like you know and
I I think we'll talk more about this so
uh Zach if we want to forestall it but I
mean like that the chunk of metal that
you have you know at what point does
that become a gun uh and does it stop
being uh you know merely a block of
metal these these are the most
interesting questions and to use your
analogy like the drug or scheduling
analogy like that's I saw California now
other states are beginning to use
a War on Drugs vocabulary to regulate
gun components and this is so much fun
they say precursor parts right precursor
parts to fire yeah the connotation's
already there that like there's
something wrong that you would have
components that might go into a gun or
fit into a gun and there's something
implied about the scheduling of these
components outside of their quality of
you know being I don't know they have
their own legal requirement for
regulation and I watched California uh
deal with this question since 2019. each
year they were just about to create a
new regime for uh precursor parts and
they even had one at one point but they
use covert to kind of skip ahead and
just accomplish what they wanted anyway
uh you know no spoilers here you're not
allowed to have them but they they ended
up merging precursor Parts with the new
enthusiasm for Banning unfinished
receivers because the states the several
liberal blue States ended up mostly just
copying language from bites Ghost Gun
World which we've already discussed here
saying well
whatever's regulated by the ATF it's
regulated here too of a funny
consequence of that is in California for
example right now California laws
really specific to the federal rules so
it says only those things that are
fairly regulated can be sold in
California
well because of vanderstock and the
future summary judgment that's got to
knock out Biden's rule California will
be in this awkward position where
their their law means nothing can be
sold in California because nothing's
federally regulated anymore
is there um is there any room for
federalism in gun laws uh you know for
you uh so you know does California have
the right or Los Angeles or San
Francisco do they have the right to have
different gun laws than uh you know uh
Dallas Texas Austin Huntsville Texas uh
where I spent two years uh you know I
mean is is there a is there room for
that or are these kind of universal
rights which must be universally
respected in all contexts that's not
that's an awesome question uh I think in
Practical terms and practical political
terms we have to make concessions like
obviously San Francisco is always going
to be hostile in a way that you know
view of Texas is not yeah what I don't
like or at least what I can't accept is
the fact that Newsome and there's this
new these Progressive nostrums mean we
have to empower our state or local
authorities to reach outside of our
state jurisdiction County jurisdiction
Municipal borders and go attack
companies uh and and people in other
states and other jurisdictions so
unfortunately though I would like to
make practical Federal Federalist
concessions in theory right because I
want to be a good American in practice
these are almost impossible to concede
now because there are some something
like Civil War conditions in the courts
and I this is not an exaggeration I
spent most of life so you're fighting
California because California passed AB
1621 and
70s well I I forget the other ones that
they had but in combination they meant
you know if you're selling something in
Texas like a ghost gun kit we'll just
Empower any of our private citizens or
gun control groups to sue you anyway so
just go just go and sue you so
unfortunately um I think we're we're
kind of in a post-federalist
conversation and um it would be deadly
to just say well I'm a good
constitutional so please everyone in
California please come see me well
speaking of California if that is you
know your greatest adversary or one of
your greatest adversaries at the moment
probably the I you you think of the the
general of that uh adversarial Army is
uh Gavin Newsom and just today he
announced that he wants to push forward
a 28th amendment that will uh kind of
enact some quote unquote Common Sense
gun regulations across the land uh and
uh I did pull a a clip from his his
announcement of that that I was curious
to get your reaction to and then we can
speak a little bit more about California
after that but first let's hear from
Gavin Newsom
every time it's the same
stop these massacres they tell us we
have to stand by and watch tragedy after
tragedy unfold in our communities they
say we can't stop domestic terrorism
without violating the Second Amendment
and the thoughts and prayers are the
best we can do
I'm here to say that's a lie so today
I'm proposing the 28th Amendment to the
United States Constitution to do just
that it raises the minimum age to
purchase a firearm from 18 to 21. it
mandates Universal background checks and
institutes reasonable waiting periods
for all gun purchases and it bans
civilians from buying assault rifles
pose weapons of war our founding fathers
never Force off this will guarantee
States as well the ability to enact
Common Sense gun safety laws while
leaving the Second Amendment intact and
respecting America's gun owning
tradition
what do you think the 28th Amendment
sound reasonable
up so so reasonable yeah so great
um yeah to me this this plays and I
don't know what his angle is here
because he says he's not running for
president but you know for the last two
years I'm sorry I hear some noise is
that me or you guys
I don't think it's us I just want to
make sure it wasn't me but for the last
two years I've seen Newsome in
particular do this weird rebranding of
I don't know the so-called positive
Liberties as the real definition of
freedom or something so I don't know if
you guys recall his little campaign but
he's like well actually freedom in
California means the right to have an
abortion you know paid for and the right
to be free you've gone violence and you
know it's part of this like I don't know
I I think he imagines it as like it's
California competing against Florida in
in persuasive redefinitions of what like
American Liberty actually means and
maybe that's sophisticated but I don't
really get the angle other than um it's
just a convenient way for people to
embrace the pink police state or
something uh and of course we all know
what his 28th Amendment thing here means
it's just a clever way of saying
liberals will always like to pretend to
be originalists or constitutionalists
when they when they grab your guns you
know it's it's pretty vulgar to me
that's my initial reaction yeah I I
wonder about and I just I'm always
wondering you know you're because you're
you're playing you're constantly playing
this game where you're trying to stay a
step ahead of what they're going to do
next and at the moment it appears you
you are a step ahead because they're
still fighting over these 80 percent
receivers and you've created the zero
percent receiver so that conversation
seems to be in different stages right
now but what one thing that California
seems to be trying to do to get after
this problem is uh to use liability laws
uh to hold either gun uh manufacturers
or gun sellers liable for
any shootings that happen with the guns
uh and what one example here uh just
earlier this week LAPD found 700 ghost
guns now it's getting five million
dollars basically they uh recovered uh
ghost guns that were used in the ambush
of some LA county sheriff's deputies in
Compton and a home invasion and a triple
murder and uh they settled with polymer
80 which is a competing ghost gun kit
seller for five million dollars so do
the seeing stories like this were you
that kind of that that's ultimately
going to be the fate of Defense
distributed that people are going to use
ghost guns to commit crimes and then
they're going to somehow try to come
after you and hold you liable if it
could be traced back to it was created
on a ghost Gunner
well unfortunately or not this is
already our reality it's not like this
hasn't happened yet Paul and Rady's
taking most of these hits these days and
I agree with you on the general approach
both of gun control and like State and
municipal authorities they imagine a
better like big tobacco-like approach
where okay the big the biggest suppliers
let's say Smith and Wesson the actual
gun suppliers they at least have the pro
forma protection of What's called the
placa if you guys know about the placa
but you know protection of lawful
Commerce and arms act something like
that so okay well they can't you know
they're still trying to pierce it right
because um you'll remember the big
Remington settlement after Sandy Hook
and that that itself was was a pretty
sad thing because like the insurers
decided to settle they didn't decide to
press the issue on the plaque or the 2A
and so I have seen consortiums you know
like illegal meats or these gun
controllers get together and say all
right our new strategy is placa we can
at least beat them all up in court and
get the insurance carriers to settle so
much that it forces you know as good
capitalists at 4 forces them to make a
safer product they'll label it
differently they'll put you know weird
orange tips and safety features on the
guns and things so that's in Earnest
their approach and of course it gives
them this pro-social whatever this kind
of progressive feeling about it while it
also masks I guess the it's pure
ideology but it also masks how well
they're actually engaging in gun control
by capitalism now rather than like
strictly as a kind of ideological
approach but uh back to your point I've
been in California alone I've also been
sued I was sued in the tahama ghost gun
shooting and a number of ghosting
companies were sued
um including Blackhawk we were sued for
500 million I think
half a billion dollars you know yeah you
get concerned when you're sued for half
a billion dollars anytime someone
has a uses a ghost gun so
uh to to the point in the in the article
that you just previewed well the
accusation that they don't do background
checks
um this is a this is a problem right
there again they're trying to redefine
the duty of care of a ghost gun company
that company's not selling guns that
company can't use the Nix system
even if it wanted to uh and so a little
bit you know this is all workshop for PR
this is all kind of part of a broader
campaign of pushing people in this
direction to make expectations have
expectations like the big tobacco fight
this is my read about it but to your
point will will this be the future of if
yes of course as as these kit guns are
used in crimes and things yes I think
we'll be hauled into every single Court
we're often threatened of it there was a
big New York suit very recently that
brought a bunch of suppliers in I think
we weren't brought in because at this
point um we have a reputation for being
very litigious like they don't always
want to just litigate with us so they
kind of pick lower hanging fruit maybe
or softer targets uh but you know look
I've gotten plenty of behind the scenes
private letters from Leticia James pick
your favorite AG you know like they're
always threatening to do and that will
be the future
do you have any idea of how many ghost
guns you know so-called uh how many
ghost guns are in circulation
I I have seen some estimates made you
know pulmonary at its height great
company
revolutionary company pulmonary at its
height was doing something like 50 000
kits a month okay and hot spots I've
heard from pollen radio and you can see
some of this corroborated by indictments
against them they had they had a big
grand jury thing a couple years ago um
hot spots for pulmonary kits were your
problem Democrat cities you know DC
Baltimore
um Oakland right do you have a sense of
you know were people uh buying the kits
you know I I guess to put it in the
context of legislators where people
buying the kits because they wanted to
commit crimes or they wanted to protect
themselves while living in a
crime-ridden city
I I think it's both I can't make a
reasonable estimate but you can see that
there are subcultures just like in
Houston it's very popular to have a
certain type of switch device that makes
your Glock more interesting uh that's a
certain type of community of people same
thing and like you could see these
subreddits for polymer 80 kit I mean
these are these are some hoodlums man at
the same time I don't know this is all
legal and uh yeah it used to buy and you
to go back to uh you know some of the
stuff that uh Gavin knew some who I I
just want to point this out because
every time I see him he looks so much
like Patrick Bateman the protagonist of
American Psycho I kind of want him to
become president just for that reason
um you know is there such a thing as
reasonable gun control
or what or are there would you say there
are
constitutionally legitimate limits on
gun ownership
uh I think I'm too much of a
postmodernist now to really commit that
answer but we're going to get to
post-modernism and uh biopolitics later
we're already there I mean we're asking
what is a gun so yeah that's true yeah
that's true well that's more surrealism
right it's like a mcgree uh right there
uh Clarence Thomas gave us the benefit
of Brewing now right so we all live
under
sign of Bruin and what does that mean
text history Traditions so we have to
make we have to make these claims even
if we don't believe in them in court now
so to your point I mean you know I can I
can give you what my best arguments are
what I think the best arguments out
there are they're happening and we're
waiting on a couple big Benitez
decisions in California uh they really
could reshape a lot of things we're
seeing a lot of gun control being struck
down and it's there is like a consistent
historical originalist narrative kind of
being applied although you'll note that
like the way we got to brew and wasn't
wasn't strictly originalism uh so I
don't know man I'm not enthusiastic
about you know when I see the word
reasonable I know it's being done there
right that's right that's a 20th century
adjustment to Norms which will allow a
certain living Constitution to always be
in effect and we just can hand wave a
little bit it's the same way like you
know like Curtis says what's it what's
the Centrist in 2020 we'll compare that
to a Centrist in 1920. you get you get
pretty radically different results same
thing with reasonable I think when you
play the longer game
yeah I mean what worries me about a a
approach that is criminalizing uh or
holding ghost Gunner manufacturers
liable for instance is that this would
seem to stretch far beyond the realm of
firearms I mean that that's why I've
always been pretty interested in your
project because I think it's it's always
been about way more than just Firearms I
mean your fight against the state
department and the ability to host gun
printing files was a First Amendment
just as much as a second amendment issue
and then if you're holding someone
liable for selling machine that can make
a gun but can also make other things
which the ghost Gunner can correct me if
I'm wrong about that uh that would seem
to really expand the reach of what is
possible to regulate and prohibit in
terms of people making their own Goods
at home yes
yeah to your point I hate to bring it
back to California but let's go back
um one reason we sued in California last
year was because they gave themselves
the power to say well okay fine you may
sell General equipment that may be a
machine that can help people make
whatever they want but if you're
marketing it in a way that will allow
people to make guns in California or
something then it's illegal for that
reason so that's that's back to a First
Amendment question I would argue of
course I think it's back to a second
amendment question too but the federal
judge didn't agree and didn't think the
plain text of the Constitution applied
to tools to help you make guns and so uh
I took a big l in court and it'll be up
to someone else probably to help it but
they they're back at it again this year
they want to ban 3D printers why they
can't ban them just as such 3D printers
as such but they can ban people selling
3D printers in a marketing context if
they're saying hey guess what you can do
with this 3D printer but then that's how
they're giving themselves the power and
to your question or to the point of your
observation that seems new
out to me that we're regulating now how
people sell things in kind of
contemplation the fact that the things
themselves are probably unapproachable
yeah I look forward to the uh you know
lawsuits against the precursor elements
of a heart attack uh you know ground
beef cheese things like that right I
mean this it becomes a kind of infinite
regress of just uh state power stop
giving them ideas man yeah now what I'm
thinking in California you know Carl's
Jr parties is based out there and that's
their old campaign right here's a big
hunk of cheese meat mayonnaise and other
artery clogging elements that you can
you know destroy yourself with so before
we get to a discussion of your uh we we
want to talk a little bit about your
first principles and kind of you know
where this these ideas first came from
but before we get to that let me just
run through a few of the audience
questions that have come in there was a
five dollar Super Chat from particle
wave will you be writing another book Mr
Wilson the first one is a gem
let me pull that up on the screen there
oh that's so cool well thanks like I you
know I don't expect softballs the whole
time either
um thanks for reading the book it was
cool you know I got I got that book out
through uh Simon Schuster before the
real wave of cancellations began you
know they canceled Milo's book right
after mine and we had the same editor by
the way
um you know it seemed to me like that
was a bit of a steal there there's some
there's some bow yard in that book
there's some kind of uh yeah
controversial stuff in that book like
hidden in there and printed in there you
can say so uh will I ever be writing a
book sure I've done way more that's
actually worth writing about I'm kind of
embarrassed when I look back at that
book it only covers the first nine
months of me ever doing anything I feel
like I have much more to I've actually
done more things worth writing about uh
but I don't think a major publisher will
be interested in anything I have to say
uh anytime soon so do you care about a
major publisher though I mean you're
isn't yeah in a strange way it's kind of
a concession to the mainstream right of
course of course I feel like the game
that I play is always at the margins of
the mainstream and that's part of it
it's like well it's not any fun unless
we're toying with Biden's ghost gun rule
you know it's not it's like of course
you can we can do anything speculative
and reach Heights that people can't find
us and can't know us that's very
interesting and cool and people should
do that
um but you know I I don't know
I I don't like doing things for free
either so but yeah at some point you
know maybe if I'm in prison I'll write
another manuscript and there you go well
yeah I mean I pulled a page from that
book actually where you talk about the
concept of the Liberator the the plastic
3D printed gun uh as the wick
conceptualizing as a Wiki weapon which
is a phrase that your friend came up
with and that you grew jealous that he
uh coined that but kind of glommed onto
it so I mean clearly you know Julian
Assange the Wikileaks was in the air at
that time Assange was a major influence
on you could you just talk a little bit
about how Assange and Wikileaks
influenced you uh it also maybe just
reflect on since you just mentioned you
know uh writing your next novel from
prison what what has happened to Assange
and what lessons you draw from his kind
of Arc yeah Assange has paid the price
hasn't he um yeah
ah and you see the you see the tide
turning on that right at this point like
Australia's his Defender and even Biden
the Biden Camp says well maybe we'll go
easy you see the New York Times pieces
being like have we been too hard on
Assange that's even in a way and this is
not to discredit a song but even even
that is like a new level of pathos that
I hadn't expected he's just so crushed
that now the liberal establishment can
even be sympathetic about it that that
sucks you know
um now I guess I want to say
yeah Assange Wikileaks that was
everything for me uh I was in law school
at the time
bored you know law school is not a place
for like intelligent people probably and
wow Wikileaks happened and this guy on
his own single-handedly defeated
obviously he had a team but he was
defeating a payments blockade he was he
was thumbing his nose at the world
hegemon and the state department oh my
God how is he doing the internet's
actually fulfilling like a cyberpunk
purpose this is crazy and uh I was like
whatever I'm doing is nothing what he's
doing
this whatever this is and so that's I
began to study this uh the cypherpunks
and the literature of join assange's
movement moment and um that's what put
me on on the path to what we did
let me pull up one more audience
question and then I want to bring up a
clip from a speech you gave that I think
pertains to this Richard Davis says if
the debate continues to revolve around
Firearms then sooner or later the
anti-libertarians are likely to Prevail
hoping for court protection hasn't been
foolproof shouldn't we be debating the
cultural conditions that lead to
criminality like the connection between
big government and individual
powerlessness which is orent discusses
causes people to become violent
um you know I don't know if you have any
specific comments on on that question
but uh what came to mind for me is this
it's been more than 10 years it's been
about just over 10 years since you
launched the Liberator and uh you know
posted that video to YouTube that caused
the media Firestorm and then brief uh
you know a few shortly after that you
gave a presentation at South by
Southwest where you kind of first
spelled out your vision and the your
purpose in doing this and lickers play a
couple excerpts from that and then talk
about
to what degree that Vision has or hasn't
been realized uh the the degree to which
you've been satisfied with the work or
disappointed with it so far so here's
the first excerpt from that 2013 South
by Southwest presentation
did you talk about what your larger
goals are with this project we we really
are being futurists can you use this
technology to print gun parts you can
print a gun that's going to be reality
sooner than a lot of people think now we
have ammunition no no but one one of the
goals is to instantiate this reality and
to move past it these objects these
shapes and it's going to extend to more
things than just the firearm but these
are going to be off off the political
table in some meaningful sense sure we
can we can pantomime a legislative
solution and I'll Pat each other on the
back oh we've saved the public
this is going to be
possible forever
so what degree do you think that Vision
has been realized so far
you know I think that talk holds up we
talked about a future of CNC we talked
about it nylon as a as a destination for
3D printing that's really happening now
in the last few years in a way that
wasn't happening for a good while that
talk holds up even I am wrong about a
lot like you know the DIY ammunition
thing that has yet to have its moment I
think it's coming and uh you know who
was I to predict any of those things but
I felt very strongly about
okay if you can print receivers you can
probably print entire guns won't be too
long and that that talk was two months
before we did Liberator for example
um our AR receivers and our AR magazines
were already really popular we had
millions of downloads at the time
um Google and the rest of these
companies didn't have the policies yet
to
censor those things so the cultural
conditions are really strong that stuff
was all over the world I just seen it
because I was doing it myself as one guy
millions of downloads all over the world
I remember GoDaddy called me and they're
like what what are you doing what is
what is this website and it wasn't a
hostel if I got that call today it'd be
like well I'm canceled but they were
like
we'll we'll give you whatever you need
we just don't understand Venture Capital
would be like what is this how can we
get on this it's like look it's just
it's clear there's a huge gradient
people of the world want this and it's
going it's going to happen so I just got
to live that lots of people since I've
got to live versions of this uh and so
I'll make one observation you said well
the Liberator video right I'll I'll
point out that that video is no longer
on YouTube no YouTube and the internet
and by and large have decided to
to play games with this stuff and the
transmission of this stuff it's much
harder to do some of this what what do
you think went into those decisions
um because in a way you know when you
think about the setting of South by
Southwest this is a you know a
conference that kind of cut its teeth on
being you know hip uh I don't want to
say progressive but future oriented a
tech oriented uh world where people were
inventing the future and it seemed like
what you were talking about then
particularly in the heels of Julian
Assange and Wikileaks like this is the
cyberpunk or uh you know or Cypher Punk
future
now you you know like you said you're
you're banned from YouTube uh you you
know I think a lot of the people who
might have been interested in what you
were saying then are like you are some
kind of [__] gun nut and you need to
be suppressed what what are the things
that went into that cultural shift well
okay there's there's like the cultural
shift of elite institutions in Elite
media and I think we all you know are
aligned on our observations there we can
go into it but there's also the cult
there's still successful cultural
transmission it's even better than it
was there's been like a let's say a
genealogy of I don't know different
snake skins of of these ideas so you
know we get jstark for example who's
become like a popular arms profit figure
of the movement and yet he suffered a
tragic death and that like really
completes this symbolic circuit and so a
lot of people's introduction to 3D uh
gun printing on the internet now is
mediated just in the last couple years
of the experience of that Community like
that's so successful so
you know it's not in jeopardy but it is
more I don't know it's uh it's more
underground it's more purposely
subcultural it does escape or or
mainstream attention is less interested
in it so there are critical differences
I would still say no matter what it's
more successful than I could have
imagined it's successful for different
reasons and even I as a kind of naive
90s kid libertarian I didn't I didn't
understand that
this this corporatist outcome where uh
really it would be a dead internet and
even now I don't know how right I am
because the AI is coming and some of the
reviews of our g0 for example uh they
can't make it to YouTube YouTube's like
nope it's not happening I mean we had
some major influencers to review it and
it's it's not happening what is it just
uh you know kind of counter-cultural
Agents uh or transgressive and
subversive agents aging out but you know
when I think of and this might be
jumping you know kind of lanes a little
bit but a group like the Electronic
Frontier Foundation which in the 90s was
absolutely Central to you know uh
defending and articulating a vision of a
free and open internet you know 20 years
later is you know in the front lines
calling for things like net neutrality I
assume they look down upon the types of
activity that you're doing and things
like that to the extent that they take
notice of it is it you know is it just
that the you know the kind of the Next
Generation has to constantly be you know
be born and push against the elders or
you know is it is there a you know a
foundational shift away from that kind
of those early visions of the internet
as a place that is uh effectively
Unstoppable and that that's one of its
its greatest attributes is just that
it's open-ended and you can't control
uh that's probably the answer if I could
speak to your last question or question
I think maybe I avoided it but um I'll
say I'll say this I want to speak well
of the eff even though I agree they're
suffering the same Temptations as every
major organization
um in American culture Cindy Cohen and
the eff they were instrumental in that
itar fight in the crypto Wars round one
and they you could tell even at the time
reluctantly backed me in my fight as
they told me even then 2013 hey you know
you're not a great plaintiff Cody and
you know what uh they're right
um but you know you can't you can't
choose your your troublemakers uh so
Cindy Cohn and she probably doesn't even
want me saying her name but you know
they they really showed up for that
first leg of the 3D gun stuff and even
American institutions of the press
showed up as Amici in federal court like
they they did understand but you could
see with the rise of trump from 15 to
17. I mean that really helped divide the
camps and it's it's all it's a totally
different chessboard since 2017 and the
rise of the so-called alt-right and
Trump and power but uh if I can Loop
this back to your last question or he
says well shouldn't we focus on
questions of cultural conditions of
criminality I don't know not so fast
um it seems to me especially now that
the American Civic religion has unified
and we all know what's woke and what's
not
um that criminality is probably an
integral necessary condition for for
Innovation and moving forward and so I
would say that I guess I'm gonna meet
you in on the question of criminality
like it's probably now the most useful
Outlook and personality so uh I don't
know but I do agree a strictly legalist
approach under conditions of wokeness is
not going to get us good outcomes and to
finally answer your question every major
institution is under the under the power
of this great American Civic religion
this great awokening your guess is as
good as mine
there's um this this idea that you have
you know you mentioned kind of Awakening
from your like naive 90s libertarianism
and kind of recognizing a vaster
array of powers or something of that
nature there's one more clip that we
pulled from the the next year's South by
Southwest 2014 that I know Nick wanted
to ask you about specifically because
you kind of uh lay out a little bit of
your theory of power and kind of
progressive management and and how that
all actually functions in the realm of
gun control but also Society more
broadly so let's uh play that and then
I'll let Nick follow up with the
question there
emancipatory political phenomena begin
with doing something
that the situation deems to be
impossible
um and of course baiju is very much
interested in certain kind of equalist
uh narratives but I mean I very much
believe that especially after Sandy Hook
um in in 2012 which I'm sure many of us
still remember much on our minds
the situation the kind of consensus
political discourse was about well how
can we further manage through a certain
Progressive managerialist Paradigm of
how the large firm uh is someone that
channels certain products into our
commercial economy how can we manage the
role of firearms in society still
further uh there was also a secondary
discourse which is how we could how
could we link guns as an issue uh how
could we further linked that issue as a
public health issue in the public
Consciousness
um this is this is a the biopolitical
element which will probably spend less
time on unless there are questions but
yeah I hate you for playing that clip
man why why
uh you know I still have I still read
bad Jews ethics but I just thought it
was so fun at the time to mix like you
know maoists and like strident uh
European Communists into the into the
program
uh but I would you know I was trying
really hard uh anyway like those
observations like they actually you know
you know they ring true and a lot of we
were talking about products liability
approaches and gun control and of course
there's this
patholog pathologizing pathologizing
pathologizing yeah yeah so it's
obviously they're always approaching you
know your theory of Mind as a gun owner
and and you know even now in the
so-called liberalized
areas of Europe where you can get a
license to carry you know you got to see
a psychologist you got to see a doctor
you got to get a license to purchase
then you get the license to carry you
know it's it's
uh it's part of the medical
establishment as well and this is part
of sawz's theory that like well
ultimately established medicine is an
agency of political power an agent of
the Court just another method of I guess
we'll bring our into it aren't and again
right biopower is here yeah yeah I I
guess uh you know what I when I look at
that clip I just see you uh channeling
among other people uh Foucault who is
being rediscovered uh or complicated not
simply as a man of the left but of the
uh kind of emancipatory right or of of a
liberal Paradigm in recent books like
the last man takes LSD
um and I want to ask you about your
inter you know your kind of intersection
with uh post-modernism or post-modernist
uh theorists but first on the on the
basic question of the the state or power
governing things like gun purchases and
mental health issues do you think in the
past decade or you know basically since
you talked about that has that become
more and more a uh you know a kind of
meme or an Avenue for the state to start
talking about who should have you know
who should have maximum rights and who
should not
well it feels like it it does feel like
there's all this this these footballs
right that the CDC should produce
certain types of reports you know you
see these definitions of mass shootings
kind of being filled with underneath the
hood and so you can get production of
um phenomena that Accord with certain
biomedical understandings or you know
like you see it a lot so people are
trying to make that narrative I don't
know how compelling it is in the end
I don't know how I at the time I was
making those
remarks like this felt to only be a
couple years old to me like every town
for gun safety didn't even get its uh
its approval letter from IRS until like
March of 13 or March 14th I don't
remember so a lot of that playbook's
being played but when I actually you
know I've kind of been in the business
of watching these regs now and I I see
them
um the personality of the state you know
the Foucault's governmentality it seems
to still be more interested in the
commercial aspect of the phenomenon
lesson lesson the biological or the
medical do you you know when it comes to
things like mass shootings particularly
school shootings
um is there anything to be done
um about that or is it you know
ultimately uh you know is a kind of a
social construction of a of a horrific
event rather than you know something
that can actually be identified
anticipated and um you know and avoid it
to the greatest degree possible
I'll make some of my friends mad I think
the Uvalde thing is the best test case
apparently that Uvaldi school was
participating in one of these AI managed
you know dredge operations it wasn't
able to predict anything and worse the
response wasn't able to be managed at
all so I no I don't really think
these narratives work yeah and yet I'm
just as in awe of you know the large
language models everyone else and all
this predictive Ai and
I don't know man I just uh
I I see like I said earlier about
fiddling with the data you know instead
you just have an Elite Class a
journalist class simply changing the
definition of what a mass shooting is
um like I said under the hood and then
CNC it's the problem's getting worse
well it you know it's just begging the
question and it serves it serves Powers
interest in the first place so
um it's a kind of elite level of concern
troll that I see and it's done in a
pretty common and easy to see way that
doesn't mean it won't work it just
doesn't seem to be as sophisticated as
my hope
you uh you've mentioned uh you you name
checked them earlier today beaujiard
um can you uh talk about who he is and
why he's important to you uh if you want
me to yes well I I wouldn't have asked
if if we weren't
I just you know I kind of fell in love
with the
discourse of bow yard it was like this
it was my first real enthusiasm for like
post Marxism you could say and in in the
end it was a it was my funny way of
approaching like questions of feminism
and questions of okay you said
emancipatory politics maybe I said it
first but approaching them from the left
but from like an aristocratic or even
nichean point of view and it just I I
just everything about not just theories
of simulation but like his theory of the
Fatal strategy and we can go into any of
it uh he seemed to me to be more of like
more actually describing what I was
looking at happening in culture in
government and politics
uh than any I mean like any of the posts
altazarian left I mean yeah okay it's
it's crystalline beautiful Theory it
doesn't actually describe what I am
looking at and what's best about [__]
is like I can make predictions with this
Siri I can do interesting things with
this Theory and so my enthusiasm was
even though bojar himself says you know
you can't really use my my theory to do
anything but Theory well bojard's best
lesson is to read your favorite author
against himself so uh I've just been
trying to use gojard's fatal strategies
and theories of games and theories of
Seduction I'm trying to infuse some of
those rules into our projects and
address a certain audience of power and
invite that power to exhaust itself Etc
I could keep going all day so what well
what's an example of how you've
implemented one of those strategies in
expanding the reach of Defense
distributed for instance sure sure any
any DD project I try to hit most of the
the points of the Fatal strategies
bojart says you have to invite chance
um the the ludic it has to be a game it
has to be addressed to a specific
um a specific audience of power it has
to be observed by that audience as a
confrontation or a challenge defeat
France like a Defiance like you are
actually bidding them to respond and so
like for example you were going to play
my ATF for my G my g0 video well who's
the who's the character and story B in
this video why it's the ATF agent
himself Mr Russell let's let's play that
let's play it and then you know we can
analyze it a little bit the Peril of
analyzing your own artwork
yeah yeah this is wonderful yeah let's
do it uh yeah go ahead
oh
[Music]
that was
foreign
[Music]
just to be clear that was a truncated
version so you can see the full version
over at defense distributed's YouTube
page but you can get some of the sense
of the Aesthetics that you've tried to
build over there what's uh you know
clearly you've you've gotten an interest
in filmmaking our visual storytelling uh
what is it that you are trying to convey
uh well we should resist exhaustive
interpretation now it's not like there's
not much to say uh the look The
addressee of most of my challenges you
know I see my projects not really as
commercial projects and that's why I'm
probably a bad businessman right like I
want them instead to be these these
gifts beaujar is a sociologist and you
know he draws from theories of gift
exchange you actually see a brief gift
exchange in that video uh and so my gift
is always like a Defiance to power in
the terms of power except for itself
challenging power to be real or to
imminentize itself you know and saying
like I don't believe that you're real
I've said things like this to you Zach
and few in in past conversations that's
part of my kind of post-democratic
theories too like you know I don't
believe you are what you say you are uh
you know become real for me please uh
jump into the internet here and let's
let's have a party let's see if you can
if you can take these files off of the
internet but in this context um the ATF
had a bad go with this Rule and I
believe leave worse not only is it a bad
rule but they disable themselves in
federal court they have no power right
now to say what is and isn't a firearm
against my company and a few others so
oh fine we'll take that and we'll
redefine the Glock firearm for example
with the G zero and you see a visual
representation there of an ATF kind of
lost in all that great Darkness you know
all it's like are you is he gonna find
his way you know uh so that's it's a
very simple visual idea but you know it
conveys one aspect of the Fatal
strategies and with we haven't even
really talked about the product that's
at the center of that video uh in in
Link in depth yet could you just explain
what it is that you are launching and
how that fits into kind of the the
progression of Defense distributed yeah
you you showed a video Joe Biden holding
up a polymer 80 kit and the pulmonary
kit is a Glock type gun that you could
basically order in the mail
nearly finished you finish it yourself
with hand tools and about you know Bing
you gotta you gotta Glock so
um his rule was about stopping
commercial kit guns in the mail and uh
if he could trying to go after 3D
printed Glocks which some other states
have done but I was like I was thinking
well okay now the rule is kind of
failing let's do another version of a
way to do a block at home okay so you
can print the frame everyone's done that
but what if this is no longer a frame
sorry I'm not good at holding this up
what if this is no longer the regulated
part what if this is the regulated part
this is a chassis
you know people in the gun world are
familiar with like the Sig P320 and
cassette style triggers and anyway the
ATF is forced to observe that the metal
component that holds the Fire Control
uh Parts is the firearm and then
combination then
um this what would have been a frame and
a Glock is no longer regulated so it's
like a it's like a doubling down against
the ATF roll they can't regulate blocks
of metal anyway they said they couldn't
a low carbon steel by the way and um you
know this is I think this is one of our
4140 frames yeah so we've been testing
17 4 41 40 303 stainless you know what's
machinable what's affordable the point
is this is this is as good uh as a
pulmonary kit or a block itself if
anything we've taken Trends in 3D
printing and kit clocks combine them
recombine them remix the Glock itself
in Stark Defiance of the terms of
Biden's ghost gun Rule and said hey good
job on that rule it was already you know
it was already falling it's push the
judge will disable it and yet here's
another way of doing it it's it's
ultimately you know addressed to the ATM
what what does it mean that um you know
over the course of your kind of public
career the courts have been very
accommodating to expansion of gun rights
uh certainly at the Supreme Court level
uh and it sounds like you know you got
your way in Texas uh in a in a federal
court
um you know are the I I guess I'm asking
is the federal Judiciary secret
bojardians or capaldians wouldn't that
be amazing
um it kind of makes sense right you know
increasingly probably for codian or
something I have to worry about the
quality of the federal Judiciary in the
next 10 years we're going to get the
most [__] opinions uh and it will
get worse and worse I really have no
faith in the Judiciary okay and yeah
that's not to besmirch some of the
relief I've gotten but dude that
injunction I got in in Texas that's
first time anything's ever gone my way
in federal court okay and it's not like
I haven't been trying so uh no I have no
faith in all this stuff and people like
worship Benitez as basically the only
light of Reason in California or in the
ninth circuit I mean we're it's it's bad
and we can say okay great we're seeing
some cool things because of Bruin man
this is like uh these are the exceptions
that prove the overall trend the rule I
have no optimism about this I just see
this as a relative moment of operational
strategic Freedom which is unexpected
and should be you know we should make
use of it but God I have no faith in the
future
could we uh talk a little bit about and
Zach I don't I don't know if we played
the clip uh where uh Cody invokes
practical Anarchy uh no I have that
though that's from the that same uh
South by Southwest uh 2013 presentation
yeah
um the second part of your answer to the
uh questioners question about what what
is the purpose what are you trying to
accomplish uh let's uh cue that up real
quick and I'm interested in creating
that world and then two I'm interested
in demonstrating practical Anarchy one I
think the web is an anarchy I think the
web is a successful Anarchy you can buy
things on eBay you can buy things on
Amazon pseudonymouscommerce Works crypto
Commerce works and these principles are
bleeding back into the real world
through Technologies like
3D printing
I guess you know but my question out of
that kind of Harkens back a little bit
to what we were discussing before uh
with uh YouTube taking down the
Liberator video we've had now with the
Twitter files coming out more evidence
that there's been behind the scenes job
owning of these companies to rein in
kind of the the realm of what is able to
be expressed on the internet uh there's
just a lot of anxiety about Gatekeepers
tightening I mean we can throw in you
know the uh you know the end of Silk
Road at least in its first iteration as
well as you know right now there seems
to be a federal move against Bitcoin and
uh cryptocurrency or or at least against
uh exchanges like finance and coinbase
so yes so do you where do things stand
then in your opinion is digital Anarchy
still a thing or is just the internet in
a fundamentally different place right
now
of course it's still a thing
um increasingly like you know this is a
complaint of the left on the internet
you know everybody larps is some type of
social Anarchist on the left uh on
Twitter you know but very few people do
the Practical organizing you actually
meet up and do anything but uh that's
probably always been internet leftism
and anarchism for you and I don't mean
to to leave out
internet anarcho capitalists you know
that's the Bitcoin side of the family
isn't it but right so of course those
things are all real and some of these
guys have gotten quite powerful and
influential but it's all too convenient
when elements of the that social
Anarchist conversation more perfectly
align uh with the interests of
the police say you know in federal power
or you could say like this um I don't
know what is it vote capitalism or
whatever um you know rainbow capitalism
uh all these things
haven't
they're not in the proper tension that
they should have so even I was like
flirting with um you know Center for a
stateless society literature feeling
more confident about like the vocabulary
of left anarchism when all this began
still I think those things are happening
those projects are valuable but um I'm
so suspicious of of like uh the
personality of like of an anti-statist
and the personality of the state that I
don't know I I think post-modernism is
actually healthier because it it removes
you from Master narratives you know an
actual commitments and ideology
um so I don't know I I'm in an
ambivalent Place yeah does it preclude
uh I mean does your world view kind of
preclude triumphalism because you know
there really is no Transcendence of
power or of uh you know you can win
certain battles you lose certain battles
but there's always another battle the
next day sure maybe that's why boat
yard's cool for me it's like a way to
play with metaphysics without having a
metaphysics but yeah okay and I think it
might be worth pointing out to people I
I suspect many of the people listening
already know that beaudryard is arguably
best known for kind of inspiring The
Matrix movies and he was supposedly even
ask by the Wachowski then Brothers now
sisters which seems to be perfectly in
keeping with everything we're talking
about to write the uh the screenplay for
the Matrix which you said no he was he
was too busy
um but that whole notion of kind of
living within different Power Systems
and either fighting or not and never
quite knowing whether or not you are you
know actually taking action or are being
kind of dreamed by someone else his uh
his later comments you know on on The
Matrix movies were pretty hard she was
saying you know
actually this is exactly the opposite of
what I'm talking about the Matrix is the
perfect example of simulation like oh
maybe I'm in an alternate he's like no
the simulation is is in fact all this
appearance which hides that there is no
ultimately reality you know there is no
naive Walter Geist or whatever
uh go ahead I'd like to just well I I
just want to dig a little bit more into
one of the comments you made there about
you were a little more comfortable than
kind of Lefty anti-status spaces at one
point and then became disillusioned with
that for for some reason could you just
spell that out a little bit more is it
that the kind of left-wing sensibility
just naturally inclines you to
be subservient to the the ruling the
powers that be like could you spell that
out a little bit for me uh yeah without
being too harsh I mean you know who
doesn't love the French Revolution
um and even I think uh
oh I was gonna if that wasn't just a
rhetorical question
many many of many of the people who were
killed any right winger would say oh I
don't love them yeah look I have
Carlisle I have Carl's full volumes on
what I mean is as a historical event you
know wow that's the definition of a
revolution you know it's uh I'm still
stuck in a 20th century discourse and a
leftist frame of mind everyone is in
America so I I'm recognizing the limits
of my own frankly common liberal point
of view you know even my libertarianism
has influenced so heavily by Marx so I
want to say all those things like I
don't think I'm better than my raising
or something but
um and not to even be too harsh about
leftist concerns but I was kind of
already in a like I was doing my post
leftist readers at the time that I that
I popped off and did this so bojar was a
good excuse for me to kind of give up on
you know shitty feminism and these
questions of equality within the you
know the gender Theology and you know I
don't like Judith Butler and
performativity and it's all kind of it
was just easy for me to dispense with it
and of course even before Trump
um the left is like a certain like a
bucket of crabs I mean you can't you're
not actually allowed to really do
anything meaningful or change the
historical coordinates without a ton of
concern trolling and so I just wanted to
give myself the Liberty to to proceed
and um and so much of leftism is
ultimately still platonic and questions
of ideals and morality and um I'm sorry
but this is
you know in its own terms these are
non-material right you're not a Marxist
if you're talking about
questions of emotional Justice and uh
you know I don't want to get I don't
want to get into it but um I I just
didn't want to waste my time
and with regards to the crypto Anarchist
project or Cipher punks
where where do you think that that
stands now because that that's kind of
what we've been driving out here with
some of these discussions uh you know I
had made a video a while back uh what
everyone was talking about the great
reset and how they're worried that the
world economic forums just gonna like
own all of us and I was kind of
advancing an argument that well I don't
know a lot of the technological Trends
are making that a lot harder in a lot of
ways I wonder where you fall on that
question are you afraid that there is
like kind of the the Techno
authoritarian super state is really
gonna win or that that it's impossible
or it's going to be like an ongoing uh
you know eternal battle uh how do you
think about that that larger ongoing
conflict
I think there's lots of reason for
optimism
I know everybody still wants the history
to have a meaning and a direction and
that there should be some World state to
satisfy us and it's you know Machines of
love and grace will
automate and give us luxury communist
conditions but you know do do I really
believe in that no I don't think it's
possible
um I just think it'll be a great mix
maybe it really will be like science
fiction and high-tech low life you know
like incredible vast
interesting reaches of technical
progress with depressingly shallow and
animal-like living conditions I mean
maybe uh I guess these are all questions
of Aesthetics really and Aesthetics
become more important than philosophy so
I do think I still read the crypto
anarchist
you know books the the pirate Utopias
are these it's so breathtaking like the
Visions they had and so much of it came
true the biggest part of that is Bitcoin
for example and if we just use the
example of Bitcoin like Peter Thiel says
this is the most significant invention
in modern times in history who knows I
mean really I don't think that's
overstatement I think 3D printed guns
are up there but bitcoin's probably
bigger why is that what what is so
revolutionary about Bitcoin from your
perspective uh it's like the first real
hard money right and sure there'll be
you know you remember when 14 and 15
year old like ah they're gonna get rid
of Bitcoin or even now they're like oh
the feds there's too much everybody's
got too much of an interest in it my
favorite part about the Silk Road ordeal
uh was agent I forget his name you know
was on the take and he was taking as
much Bitcoin as he could so it's like a
Philip K dick novel right yeah I mean it
totally is where the the drug uh agents
are in on the on the deal right so I you
know this there will always be a demand
for hard money and you know there's
there's some boat yard in here we don't
have time for it probably I just I think
the crypto anarchists and fundamental
senses were absolutely right we don't
even realize how right they were they
were so right they didn't know how right
they were
um do you feel though on the right then
you know and when you think of people
like Peter Thiel and and if not him
specifically people who are kind of in
his orbit uh you know they seem to be
going tripling down on anti-woke things
and a need to go back to you know uh the
Bronze Age or more traditional forms of
family and social organization is that
fundamentally an aesthetic choice on
their part
um or is it do they misunderstand the
you know kind of the very idea is or the
world that they're kind of ushering in
um and should you know should the rest
of us be concerned uh when we hear
theorists on both the right or on the
left and increasingly on the right talk
about post-liberal uh you know the need
for post-liberal politics where uh we
need to get out of this Enlightenment
trap
um yeah yeah that seems to be
undergirding all of the material
progress that we've had well I'm as
interested in that last part of your
question as anyone and I'm trying to be
there all the time I'm looking for
Spooks over my shoulder too but the
first part of your question is like um
maybe the more interesting thing if you
can even consciously make the choice to
like pick a counter tradition you know
you're actually you are a postmodernist
you just don't know it this is the whole
thing with Jordan Peterson which is
interesting like well it doesn't matter
just pick a narrative and it's like well
damn do that that's the most postpart
that you can do it Traditions have to be
grounded and I have been thinking since
Bruin happened at least we've the courts
have demanded that in this specific
Second Amendment context we are required
um to be in a tradition or to at least
make an argument or to be in this
tradition it's not a tradition it's a
very specific tradition which still has
the uh Power of law so there's like a
post-modern humanist Grace that Clarence
Thomas has given us and uh it's even
better than that I don't mean to be
cynical there I love the fact that you
know he's an African-American right and
he himself corrects the problems
uh in some of these old racist cases
which denied the people had the right to
bear arms but he's doing it as a way of
asserting liberal universalism against
liberal universalists he knows this and
you can read it to mean that
um
oh gosh what was that what was that
Supreme Court case uh the worst one that
said black people aren't human beings uh
Plessy uh well uh the Dred Scott
Decision
people have no rights that whites need
respect in Dred Scott is this
observation I forget it's Taney or
someone who says yeah well of course of
course black people can't
you know have the right to keep him bear
arms you know they're not they're not
people they're not citizens it's
something like that and it's like Well
Clarence reversed that you know and he's
made everyone all the liberal
universalists
uh have to cringe under their own
religion you know and that's what's so
funny about anyway I'm getting us off
track but I I think sure if you can
choose a a lifestyle or something you
just don't realize how in each year or
postmodern You Are by just saying well
I'm going to choose to be a momfluencer
and you know go be like uh live on a
farm on Instagram well you're you know
you're actually living on Instagram
you're not living on a farm
let me run through just to before we
close out here let me run through a few
more of the audience questions one is
here from Trent Dugan here for ghost
tanks uh a related one is DIY ammo real
I guess you know what both of these are
kind of about are like how far can this
actually be taken
um will DIY ammo ever be real will ghost
tanks or you know some large
uh illegal weapon uh be one day
manufactured in someone's garage
dude I've been seeing ghost javelins all
over the world I wonder how that
happened I thought I thought those were
going to Ukraine uh you know I've been
seeing a huge spare part Market too for
drones and javelins what's that about so
much look into that so of course all of
these things I think uh let's say like
let's diagnose our condition are we in
the are we in the late Republic of
America are we in the late Empire right
these are questions of post post liberal
concern well your answer that question
may determine just how ghosty the
weapons markets get and is DOI I'm a
real sure of course it is you can make
you know you can do your own hand loads
and make your own ammunition today I
think the question means is some type of
commercial
or let's say kit form of this stuff in
DIY available
uh very nearly I mean reloading is
always a big thing and we've been
studying primers lots of people have set
themselves to these tasks so yeah I
think in time there will be better
answers than there today
then a couple comments from a Critic
here
uh RG Galvin if you make your own gun
for personal use you should have to
register it why should you not have to
register it you can have a baby without
you can't have a baby without getting at
a social security number or birth
certificate should you why then this
goes on what's the argument he wants to
make and sell guns to anyone he chooses
without government oversight
I think um maybe one of the
misunderstandings here is I you know I
may console equipment right I'm making
sell accessories but importantly I don't
sell guns and um
yeah it's a pretty big oversight in his
thesis and of course you can have a baby
and that baby there's no reason that
baby needs a social security number you
know that's something I will tell you
this if you have a baby at an American
Hospital I know with my younger son uh
who turned 21 or he's about to turn 22.
I got his social security card before I
got his birth certificate uh in the mail
wow and uh I did not apply for either of
those things so wow okay you know uh wow
I would I'll say there's still an
interest in uh unregistered people just
like unregistered guys there's plenty of
stateless people in this world and again
like uh this quality of statelessness or
you know being outside of government
observation is increasingly necessary
for just the smooth functioning of
society
can I uh to kind of follow up on that
and and these questions of Bio power
biopolitics and uh you know you
mentioned Giorgio Agame in passing we've
talked a little bit about Michelle
Foucault who really focused on the idea
of biopower and biopolitics which is the
ability of the state or a source of
power typically the state to actually
manipulate the bodies of of its subjects
um
is that growing or is that decreasing in
any meaningful what
well it's growing as a justification on
both sides like both sets of extremists
I'm thinking of Curtis here too I mean
Salas popularized the ultimate thing
right so everybody wanted to use covid
for their agenda right like everybody
you know so this is probably not even
like a good observation it's just it
increasingly becomes and I think
especially with advances in
biotechnology yeah okay we're really
going to get an overcharged but but
covet is the is the prime I think right
and it's fascinating a garment uh for
people who are not familiar with them is
an Italian philosopher who gained a huge
amount of uh Renown and credibility in
the West when he uh basically said that
911 was ushering a in a state of
exception to Liberal uh politics that
was ruinous uh and the the academic left
in the US absolutely loved him right up
until the moment when covet hit when he
applied exactly the same argumentation
to the covet regime in Italy uh and then
he was kind of written off by the left
as a you know dangerous Madman
yeah again we used to be celebrated for
not getting on planes not giving
fingerprints you know I remember all
this like uh his his state of exception
is is a great analysis of Schmidt right
and a great announcement as well
studying these theories of justification
for manipulating the BIOS you know are
are there answers there I don't know I
have his Omnibus like there's really
cool stuff about uh what he calls the
stasis right the period before Civil War
you know in darker times I want to amp
myself up and say oh no we're in a
stasis now but we're in some kind of
cold Civil War which is mediated by um
like pulos as a pink police state or
some kind of weird conditions of
capitalism it doesn't it doesn't behave
according to standard Marxist terms and
I I think you're spinning certainly
enough if you're if you're studying it
do you do you feel like and you've had
some developments in your own uh
personal legal uh tribulations uh say
um have you been the victim of Bio power
or biopolitics
um and
uh I don't think so I mean I I don't
wanna I wanna choose not to you know
make excuses or see myself as some kind
of victim or something so I will say you
know graciously I was uh finally
completed my probation and my case was
dismissed and I'm in a fortunate
position to have not received any kind
of felony convictions or something
that's great most people aren't that
kind you know they're not lucky I could
say the facts of my case were
we're good enough to where I could avoid
conviction but you know you have to
understand these are the conditions that
were that we're playing in right now and
like uh you know dominandi great book by
the way you know if you want to do
really interesting and cool things you
probably should be above reproach or at
least attempting to be so that you don't
frustrate your message or you know don't
complicate your symbolic points so it
was a big education I'll say that yeah
do you feel you know and and I mean this
kind of brings it back to a uh you know
a more grounded uh you know kind of
conversation range is Criminal Justice
Reform which is something you know that
you know kind of Hit the mainstream
maybe with the Michael Ferg uh the
Michael Brown case in Ferguson in a
profound way you know through George
Floyd through Donald Trump
um you know is Criminal Justice Reform
one of these places where a kind of
practical Anarchy seems to be happening
where the police State uh the
surveillance maybe not the surveillance
that but the police state seems to be
losing a little bit of power yeah
you know I'm Tim I've been tempted to
say yes on this but I just I I see all
that it was just Trump
trying to be some kind of popular figure
you can't let it go you know he's not
it's not really a commitment of his he
just wants to be seen in a photo with
Kim Kardashian it's that simple and it's
mechanics I think yeah Trump himself is
not that simple maybe but there's
questions of like sincerity and
profelicity here like really interesting
sociological questions
you know I would say Criminal Justice
Reform is just a another of these of
these scenarios or personas on which you
know we that we can play to and take on
but in fact there's an intense liberal
Metropol interest in actually still
addressing the criminal problem and we
see these adjustments made like in gun
control right where okay sure you know
no bail everybody's out 20 charges but
like uh I'm a felon if the you know if I
use the right adopter you know so for uh
you know red flag laws perhaps or uh you
know in case of kind of pushing in to
the mental health aspect of you know gun
owning a gun is a fundamental human
right in America right it's a
constitutional right it's the second
most important you know by number
um but here is a mental you know a
growing number of mental health
exceptions to that it it seems that the
Criminal Justice Reform thing is just an
accommodation made to the just the
latest updated form of the American
Civic religion it's meant to be
contradictory you don't look too much
into it it's convenient that this these
beliefs are held in the widest
demographically areas of the country I'm
thinking of the East Coast you know
um it's just it's all too convenient for
me and again I'd like to reduce things
to the level of like what is actually
happening how is this actually working
uh it's still like a cultural State it's
going to be one
um that's not changing
in terms of what is happening
politically uh you you know you you
mentioned Trump
I interviewed you a couple weeks before
Trump won in 2016 and you you more or
less predicted he was going to win at
the time I think brexit had just
happened
um and now you know you're saying we're
in this uh cold Civil War as you put it
I mean do you literally believe that
something is likely to pop off here like
are you
thinking going into that we're about to
enter another election season that's
when things heat up like are you
actually worried Something's Gonna Break
Out and if so uh do you feel any
hesitation you know shipping out ghost
gutters across the land so no I I don't
think if you mean like hard like
violence or something I mean we've
already seen the summer Floyd and all
this stuff like they can do that
whenever they want I don't I don't think
they need to and the let's say the right
wing in this country is not meaningfully
opposed ballot harvesting mail-in
ballots I think they've actually got it
sewn up even if Trump is the nominee I
think they've got it sewn up and Trump
uh why why would he be empowered to
adjust the outcome this time he wasn't
last time you know he's he's uh I'm just
saying like I think it's all sewn up and
and I don't have to by saying when you
say it's all set up you mean that the
Democratic candidate will win in 2024.
I believe that yeah I believe yeah and
now of course it's so far out damn you
for making me commit to that but I mean
you know can I well you know you had
said you uh I somewhat ingest that
you're stuck in 20th century thinking a
little while ago you know was there a
moment uh you know was there a moment of
disruption where we moved into you know
that 20th century Paradigm the kind of
post-war era or what we you know kind of
associate with that
um and what is what is keeping us from
moving into a you know a kind of mental
or psychological or social
um you know philosophical framework that
is actually post-modern or or is widely
recognized as such is it
um you know are there events that happen
that will kind of Usher this in or is it
a kind of just a common recognition oh
that we're we actually all even the most
traditionalist among us are actually
living in a post uh you know a post
modern reality where we're choosing
among disparate uh you know disparate
ends uh you know how do is does any of
that stuff have to happen
well I think a lot of us are living
in an understood 21st century condition
I mean covet happened a lot of us
recognize the precarity of our situation
legally Etc okay the fiction and the
mythology of the country's here but the
rituals are fundamentally different post
covet post a burgerfel a lot of us are
sensitive to that and live with this
understanding of this difference so I'm
not saying we're just all asleep but it
is so tempting to reach for 20th century
styled solutions to what has happened so
I think that's that's part of it and
then we've just been instructed for so
long in the theory of the leftist
intellectual or revolutionary that we
think well I know I'll be I'll become a
men's rights activist and I'm sorry to
mra's out there it's just uh this is not
compelling uh there's uh same thing with
even the gun thing it's like well the
gun is a human right and I'll argue for
it in court and the courts will
understand that is not what a federal
court is I mean these are questions of
pure Precision Power at this point you
know who's in group who's out group I'm
sorry that it's like that don't think it
should be like that but it's only going
to increasingly be like that so my only
hope is that okay 21st century or not
Texas or the fifth circuit becomes this
real Breakaway Republic in legal terms
the circuits are got these totally
outside decisions you know um gosh
especially not just in guns but in all
kinds of stuff so I'm just hoping for
a breakup in distinct legal and
Commercial ways and uh let's let's hope
that those fault lines can we can we can
inch forward we can dig in and that
gives us time did I answer the second
part of your question though
I'm not sure I remember it so I I'm
gonna say that you did so let me ask uh
a kind of final question I'll leave the
the last one for Nick uh I I wanted to
ask Beyond guns
um yeah where do you think
things might uh what are your biggest
hopes for this movement that you are one
of the figureheads of to expand into
Beyond Firearms or money in the form of
Bitcoin is there any other fertile
ground that you think is there that uh
this kind of uh you know crypto anarchic
or Cypher Punk ethos can really thrive
in the 21st century
yeah I mean I'm we're seeing
opportunities all the time with AI right
what have we learned about you know the
lobotomized God that the left has
created well it won't tell you about how
to make a gun
and if someone does you might be able to
guess at least at this point in the
internet that that might be a human
being helping you uh or we should
develop our own right so we've done AI
experiments for years here we did text
models text-to-speech we've got our own
chat Bots and stuff and if you are a
breakaway startup a company or any you
know you're interested in the post
political and you want to be commercial
I think you need AI I think uh you
should definitely be experimenting with
compute and with all the cool stuff like
in stable diffusion and llms so I think
I should be a part of it I I don't think
I'm just chasing a trend there
um these things are very powerful tools
and there seems to be just almost a
total alignment with using them in only
one direction to support the message you
know the narrative and so it's trivially
easy so free of AI yeah let the AI uh be
a free thinker 30 billion parameter
model llm you can train on a laptop
right now I mean just to lower all these
things like every week you're seeing
these Innovations where I'm actually we
should be seeing all kinds of
interesting technical developments from
Libertarians and so-called capitalists
uh it's interesting that we're not
do I I guess as a final question
um you know you we've talked a little
bit about how Aesthetics may you know
actually be more important than
philosophy or even material
circumstances uh and I I assume that
that's partly because we've reached a
level of uh you know whether we want to
call it super abundance or just material
richness that people are dealing much
more symbolically than you know on a
kind of the lower rungs of have uh
Maslow's hierarchy what are the
Aesthetics uh that you think kind of
Define or point to a richer
understanding of the the current moment
of you know both the you know Return of
the Empire the Reven you know the the
Empire striking back but also this
liberationist moment is it you know is
it glitchard is it the endless
iterations of nft art are there you know
is there an aesthetic conception that
kind of gets at what the stakes are and
what the possibilities are damn it's a
big one
um
well Aesthetics has morality right like
the beautiful is the good so
um look there's tons of
uh jailbroken
free uncensored models out there right
image models where these people are
feverishly committed to making you know
the most beautiful type of woman
possible or something I mean this is an
act these are active projects in
development huge communities Rivals with
each other mediated by 4chan uh well
regardless of their ideology or whatever
their justifications are they are doing
the silent work of some kind of unseen
God to create the most beautiful thing
possible I mean that this is happening
so I would say the Aesthetics of certain
Discord channels for those creating
these desperate models like that that's
one answer to the question I think yeah
that's a pretty good answer
I gotta say uh well Cody Wilson thank
you very much for uh joining us for this
conversation it was uh fascinating as
always and uh Nick thank you as well and
for all of our viewers who tuned in and
who watched later we'll be back here
again next Thursday at one o'clock see
you then thank you